Kourtney Kardashian and Eunice Benjamin  heat things up in France  [Music]  just when it seemed like things might be  cooling off between the Keeping Up with  the Kardashians star and the 23 year old  model they were spotted in San Tropez  being all kinds of adorable really cute  the lovebirds were photographed taking  in the summer Sun on a boat and boarding  a helicopter for a romantic ride  together the 38 year old posted to  snapchat while airborne and even shared  this sneaky pic of both her and Eunice's  feet back on the ground they perhaps the  cutest snap of all you guys are freaking  me out are there photos of me on the  Internet but they don't want to be out  there courts man got behind the lens and  captured a few moments with the reality  star with some sweet music in the  background  [Music]  the two first sparked romance rumors in  May when they stepped out for a dinner  date in LA and were later spotted  cuddling in can  [Music]